I'm grateful to them I'm grateful to
every single one of you this has been an
honor thank you
Trevor Noah emotional saying goodbye to
the Daily Show after seven years you
know I think you you strive to achieve
critical Acclaim when doing what you do
on television but I will never forget
that the people are possible are the
people who actually watch the show so if
you watch me you're more important to me
than any award and any critic the
comedian hosted his final episode
Thursday Trevor taking some time to
reminisce about his early days on The
Late Night show I remember all my shows
people didn't there weren't tickets that
you know everyone was empty seats
um and then I then I look at this now I
don't take it for granted ever every
seat that has ever been filled to watch
something that I'm doing I always
appreciate because I know the empty seat
that sits behind it so thank you and
Trevor got emotional giving a special
shout out to the women in his life
there's people like oh Trevor you're so
smart and you saw and then like I'm like
who do you think teaches me
you know who do you think has shaped me
nourished me informed me
you know from my mom my grand you know
my aunts all these black women in my
life but then in America as well if you
I always tell people if you truly want
to learn about America
talk to black women
talk to black women they are they're a
lot of the reason that I'm here and so
I'm grateful to them I'm grateful to
every single one of you this has been an
honor thank you I strive to make the
best show possible but without somebody
appreciating what I do I have no job and
so I make the show for them and them
first and so I listen to my fans and the
people who actually watch my show Trevor
took over The Daily Show after Jon
Stewart's departure in 2015. growing up
in the dusty streets of South Africa I
never dreamed that I would one day have
well two things really
um and indoor toilet
and and a job as host of The Daily Show
how much has my life changed I wake up
earlier I watch more of the news and I
stress a lot more than I used to that's
one of the biggest things I took for
granted is not watching the news really
calms you as a human being fast forward
seven years later and Trevor announced
he's stepping down as host it's been one
of my greatest Joys I I I've loved
trying to figure out how to make people
laugh even when the stories are
particularly on the worst days you know
we've laughed together we've cried
together
um
but after seven years I I feel like it's
it's it's time so who's taking over The
Daily Show No official announcement has
been made yet but one thing is for sure
Trevor's excited for his next chapter do
you do you have plans on what you're
going to do next or everything
everything everything everything I'm
gonna get
I'm gonna get drumming lessons from
Quest yeah getting our drumming lessons
going yeah of course yeah no you know
what I I I'm so excited to do everything
[Music]
foreign